[Musique]
certains scientifiques ont prédit ce qui
est arrivé mais il était déjà trop tard
[Musique]
ici ça maul dana si quelqu'un écoute
toujours ses émissions c'était ma
décision de rester sur terre
ici le dr harry warden fréquences
d'émission 90 points 43 km le monde que
nous considérions autrefois comme le
nôtre semble s'en prendre à nous le
principe fondamental de la nature et de
survivre c'est non seulement créé dans
notre adn mais aussi dans notre âme de
chercher à vivre par tous les moyens
j'ai capté ses transmissions radio où
sont les autres
y'a que nous deux vous avez vu d'autres
villes ouais c'est pareil partout
vous pouvez me dire comment c'était je
veux dire avant je comptais être
professeur on n'était pas prêt pour ça
vous rejoignez le dernier décollage vers
you on lui fait pour mon père rio
n'était que le dernier recours j'ai vu
des dizaines de personnes mourir de faim
parce qu'on lui a fait confiance je
commettrais pas la même erreur une
seconde fois et en parquant faut prévoir
notre itinéraire mais on ne doit pas
tarder la route est longue si jamais on
se plante on est fini il faudra y passer
la nuit
c'est pas possible si c'est possible
c'est que l'on est les endroits que j'ai
visités alors c'est parti
le site de lancement a été déplacée on
est coincé
temps
crois moi
[Musique]